Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je réponds à la question
d'Anthony, qui me demande :
« Comment développer
le patrimoine immatériel? »
Anthony, beaucoup de gens ignorent
ce qu'est le patrimoine immatériel.
Mais ici,
sur le site de l'UNESCO,
justement, il y a une description de ce qu'est
du patrimoine immatériel et ça comprend
également les traditions, les expressions
vivantes, héritées de nos ancêtres
transmises à nos descendants comme
traditions orales, arts du spectacle,
pratiques sociales, rituels et événements
festifs, connaissances et pratiques
concernant la nature et l'univers,
connaissance de savoir-faire nécessaire
à l'artisanat traditionnel. Alors, tu peux
comprendre que le patrimoine immatériel,
c'est énorme. Mais comment le développer?
Je pense que c'est tous les jours
au quotidien qu'on va transformer nos
manières de faire. Et présentement,
je pense qu'une des choses qui est la plus
importante, c'est de conserver celui qu'on
a et qui, malheureusement, n'a pas été
justement protégé de façon adéquate.
C'est à dire de garder des expressions,
de garder des recettes, des traditions
qui sont des fois moins connues,
moins partagées dans les livres d'ethnologues
ou d'anthropologues, mais qui font partie
de la richesse très subtile des communautés
et des cultures. Donc, comment on utilise
des poches de thé pour faire de la soupe
au castor, ou bien quand le porc-épic
est travaillé, est utilisé en artisanat.
Ça fait partie des patrimoines
immatériels, mais aussi des fois
les expressions qui sont nées des histoires
qui ont été vécues dans des communautés.
Donc c'est de les répertorier,
de les conserver
et de continuer à les faire avancer
et progresser dans la vie de tous les jours.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils vont s'adapter
à l'internet, qu'il vont s'adapter à notre
vie au travail, au 9 à 5.
Anthony, ta question extrêmement grande.
J'espère y avoir répondu correctement,
mais j'espère aussi que ça va vous
intriguer sur découvrir le patrimoine
immatériel des communautés autour
de nos villages de nos villes
et de vous y intéresser et de justement,
en les transmettant, les faire vivre.
Alors, je vous souhaite une très belle semaine,
j'espère que vous allez partager le vidéo
et nous envoyer des questions à Parole autochtone.